Thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for underwriting this special two-part series about the power of sound to affect and influence our health and well-being. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is working alongside others to build a culture of health for everyone in America. Learn more about them at rwjf.org. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Nearly everywhere we go, we're bombarded with human-made sound. It's especially bad in cities.
感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会赞助了这个关于声音对我们的健康和福祉产生影响和影响的力量的特殊的两部分系列。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会正与其他人合作，为美国每个人建立一种健康文化。在 rwjf.org 上了解更多关于他们的信息。这是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。几乎在我们去往的任何地方，我们都充斥着人造声音。在城市里尤其糟糕。
Cities in the past think about where you'd have horses and Buggies, you know, you hear clopping, you'd hear banging of wood against stone. Very noisy experiences. That's Joel Beckerman. He's a composer and founder of a Sonic Branding and Design Company called Manmade Music. Then cars came along and were sharing the road with these horses. And so not only did you have the horses at one rate of speed, the cars at a different rate of speed, so lots of honking of the horns, it must have been a cacophonous mess.
过去的城市，想想马和马车所在的地方，你知道的，你会听到蹄声，你会听到木头撞击石头的声音。非常嘈杂的经历。那是乔尔·贝克曼。他是一位作曲家，也是一家名为“人造音乐”（Manmade Music）的声音品牌与设计公司的创始人。然后汽车出现了，与这些马共享道路。因此，不仅有以一种速度行驶的马，还有以不同速度行驶的汽车，所以有很多按喇叭的声音，那一定是一场刺耳的混乱。
But things got even worse when cars came to dominate the roads. If you fast forward to really what the soundscapes were, let's say in the 50s. So in the 50s, it was all about muscle cars. It was all about the loudest car you could have, Mustangs, Corvettes that were really, really loud. We might not have muscle cars anymore, but our cities are still noisy places. We're pretty good at tuning it out, but our sonic environments have serious impacts on our mental and physical health.
但当汽车开始统治道路时，事情变得更糟糕了。如果你快进到50年代真正呈现的声景。所以在50年代，全都是肌肉车。全都是你能买到的最响亮的汽车，野马、科尔维特，声音真的非常非常大。我们现在可能没有肌肉车了，但我们的城市仍然是嘈杂的地方。我们很擅长屏蔽它，但我们的声音环境对我们的身心健康有着严重的影响。
So, is the blaring modern soundscape slowly killing us? This is part one of a two-part series, all about how sound can be designed to create more well-being and reduce harm. We really respond to sound quicker than any other sense. It really becomes the arbiter of all our senses. But many of the sounds we hear are created with very little thought for how they interact with each other. They could be a byproduct, like engine sounds or the home of a computer, or they could be made intentionally
那么，震耳欲聋的现代声景是在慢慢杀死我们吗？这是一部两部分系列的第一部分，全关于如何通过设计声音来创造更多的福祉并减少伤害。我们对声音的反应确实比任何其他感官都要快。它确实成为了我们所有感官的仲裁者。但我们听到许多声音的创造，却很少去思考它们是如何相互作用的。它们可能是副产品，比如发动机声音或计算机的嗡嗡声，或者它们可能是故意制作的
like alarms or cell phone pings. Add to that the sound of overhead planes, air conditioning units, patios and stores pumping out music, sirens and people talking loudly to be heard over the rest of the noise. You have trucks, buses, other kinds of transit, and then mechanical things like construction. And of course, there are cars. The sound of cars is kind of inescapable, which is depressing if you think about it.
就像警报器或手机提示音。再加上头顶飞机的声音、空调机组、庭院和商店播放的音乐、警笛声以及为了盖过其他噪音而大声说话的人们。你还有卡车、公共汽车、其他类型的交通工具，然后是像建筑这样的机械东西。当然，还有汽车。汽车的声音可以说是无处不在的，如果你仔细想想，这挺让人沮丧的。
That's Kate Wagner, you might know her from her fantastic blog, McMansion Hell. She's an architecture and design critic, and she cares a lot about sound. Cars tends to drown out other things, like bird song, human speech, the rustling of leaves, conversation, things that maybe are more personal or like that we hold in it higher like aesthetic value. Joel Buckerman says we need a new approach to sound. One where we decide what we hear in our everyday
那是凯特·瓦格纳，你可能从她的精彩博客“豪宅地狱”（McMansion Hell）中认识她。她是一位建筑和设计评论家，并且她非常关心声音。汽车往往会淹盖其他声音，比如鸟鸣、人声、树叶的沙沙声、谈话声，这些东西可能更具个人色彩，或者我们对它们抱有更高的审美价值。乔尔·布克曼表示我们需要一种处理声音的新方法。一种我们决定在日常生活中听到什么的
environment. It's really about how do we use music and sound to make people's lives richer and simpler. Joel wants sound to be something we're thinking about all the time, but while cities have more noise laws than ever, over half of the world's population live in urban areas experiencing way too much noise. The sound is measured in decibels, the louder the sound, the higher the number, areas experiencing way too much noise. Sound is measured in decibels. The louder the sound, the higher the number, a quiet library is around 40 decibels.
环境中。这实际上是关于我们如何利用音乐和声音来使人们的生活更丰富、更简单。乔尔希望声音成为我们一直思考的事情，但是虽然城市的噪声法比以往任何时候都多，但世界上过半的人口生活在经历过多噪声的城市地区。声音以分贝为单位来衡量，声音越大，数字越高，经历过多噪声的地区。声音是以分贝为单位来测量的。声音越大，数字越高，安静的图书馆大约是40分贝。
Car noise can be anywhere from like 65 to 80 to even 90 decibels if you're really close to the highway. The decibel scale isn't linear. That means 80 decibels isn't twice as loud as 40. It's actually 10,000 times louder. If you've ever had to pull over on the side of the highway, because maybe you have a flat tire or something, get out of your car. The sheer noise that you hear is quite startling,
汽车噪音可能在 65 到 80 甚至 90 分贝之间，如果你离高速公路真的很近的话。分贝标度不是线性的。这意味着 80 分贝不是 40 分贝的两倍。它实际上是 10,000 倍。如果你曾经不得不在高速公路路边停车，因为你可能车胎瘪了之类的，下车。你听到的纯粹噪音是非常惊人的，
just like the sheer mass of sound that is an 8-lane highway. The average level of car noise in a busy city is about the same as having your TV on at top volume all the time. Of course, some city noises are designed to be loud. Police sirens and ambulance sirens are 120 decibels. We might try to escape all this by sticking in a pair of headphones and cranking up the volume, but depending on what you're listening to, headphones can be over 90 decibels. Prolonged exposure to anything over 80 decibels will lead to hearing loss.
就像8车道高速公路那排山倒海般的音浪一样。繁忙城市中汽车噪音的平均水平，基本上和把电视机开到最大音量看是一样的。当然，有些城市噪音被设计得很响亮。警笛和救护车警笛是120分贝。我们可能会试图通过塞上一副耳机并把音量调大来逃避这一切，但根据你听的内容，耳机的声音可能会超过 90 分贝。长期接触任何超过 80 分贝的声音都会导致听力损失。
So, before we go any further, while we're talking about the idea of sound and health, do yourself a favor, get into a little bit quieter area, and turn this episode down a couple of notches. Your ears will thank you. When it comes to city sound, volume is not the only thing hurting us. It's not just how loud the sound is, it's the character of the sound, it's whether or not you have control over the situation. That's Erica Walker. She's a researcher at the Boston University School of Public Health
所以，在我们继续之前，在我们讨论声音和健康的概念时，帮自己一个忙，到一个稍微安静一点的地方，把这集的音量调低几档。你的耳朵会感谢你的。说到城市的噪声，音量并不是唯一伤害我们的东西。不仅仅是声音有多大，而是声音的特征，以及你对这种情况是否有控制权。那是埃里卡·沃克。她是波士顿大学公共卫生学院的研究员
and a Robert Wood Johnson Foundation grantee. For Erica, the impact of sound is all about context. I lived in an apartment building and above me were these neighbors, and they had two small kids. And the kids used to run across the floor 24 hours a day. The sound wasn't more than 50 or 60 decibels. That's the same volume as the background music and a coffee shop, but Erika could feel that sound
也是罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会的资助获得者。对埃里卡来说，声音的影响完全取决于语境。我曾住在一栋公寓楼里，楼上是这些邻居，他们有两个小孩。孩子们经常24小时在地板上跑来跑去。声音没有超过50或60分贝。这和咖啡店里的背景音乐音量一样，但埃里卡能感觉到那个声音
every moment of every day. I think for different people, it's different things, but for me, it was the rumbling. It's that low frequency sound. You can't hear it, but you know it's there. And you don't know where it's coming from, but you can feel it. Living so close together, we're going to make sounds
每天的每分每秒。我想对不同的人来说是不同的东西，但对我和来说，那是隆隆声。那是低频声音。你听不到它，但你知道它在那里。你不知道它来自哪里，但你能感觉到它。住得这么近，我们会制造出声音
that will cross over into other people's spaces. And that's not always bad. In fact, it's one of the reasons why I love living in city. Some communities say that they appreciate the sound levels like they like hearing their neighbors at the barbecue because it makes it feel like a sense of community. So there is a positive aspect. But when we don't have control, that's when health problems start. Matthias Basner is a professor at the University of Pennsylvania.
会跨入别人的空间。这并不总是坏事。事实上，这也是我喜欢住在城市的原因之一。一些社区说他们欣赏声音水平，就像他们喜欢听到邻居在烧烤一样，因为这让他们有一种社区感。所以有积极的一面。但是当我们失去控制时，健康问题就开始了。马蒂亚斯·巴斯纳是宾夕法尼亚大学的教授。
He studies how noise affects our sleep. So noise is stress, especially if we have little or no control over it. And so the body will excrete stress hormones like adrenaline and cortisol that lead to changes in the composition of our blood and of our blood vessels, which actually have been shown to be stiffer after a single night of noise exposure. People who are a relevantly exposed for prolonged period of time have an increased risk for cardiovascular disease, including high blood pressure and myocardial infarction,
他研究噪音如何影响我们的睡眠。所以噪音就是压力，特别是如果我们对它几乎没有或根本没有控制权的时候。因此，身体会分泌肾上腺素和皮质醇等应激激素，这会导致我们血液成分和血管发生变化，事实上，在接触单晚噪音后，血管已经被证明会变得更硬。长期受到相关暴露的人患心血管疾病（包括高血压和心肌梗死）的风险增加，
but also in some studies, a higher risk of stroke. A myocardial infarction, by the way, is another term for a heart attack. Although the risk increases are relatively mild, you know, relative to other exposures like smoking, for example, this still constitutes a major public health problem because so many people are exposed to these different noise sources. The World Health Organization published a report on the burden of disease by environmental noise, and they basically showed that in the Western European
但在某些研究中，中风的风险也更高。顺便说一句，心肌梗死是心脏病的另一个术语。尽管风险增加相对较小，你知道的，相对于吸烟等其他暴露因素而言，这仍然构成了重大的公共卫生问题，因为这么多人暴露在这些不同的噪声源中。世界卫生组织发布了一份关于环境噪声引起的疾病负担的报告，他们基本上表明，仅在西欧
member states alone, 1.6 million healthy live-years are lost every year due to the exposure to environmental noise. There's a study from the University of Michigan that looked at the effect of low-range sound exposures by five decibels. That could save 3.9 billion dollars in health care costs, and it would also save lives. There are so many other ways that noisy environments are bad for you. Think about a loud restaurant. There's the sound of the open bar, thumping music. You're shouting at your friend, and everyone else is shouting at their friends too. It's pretty stressful. And when we get stressed, studies show we reach for comfort food and alcohol.
成员国内，由于接触环境噪声，每年有160万健康生命年白白流失。密歇根大学有一项研究探讨了低频声音暴露减少五分贝的效果。这可以节省39亿美元的医疗保健费用，还可以挽救生命。吵闹的环境对你有害的还有很多很多其他方式。想想喧闹的餐厅。有开放式酒吧的声音、震耳欲聋的音乐。你对朋友大喊大叫，其他人也对他们的朋友大喊大叫。这压力挺大的。而当我们感到压力时，研究表明我们会去寻找慰藉性食物和酒精。
Noise also hurts our academic performance, it screws up our mood, it hurts our concentration, basically we are being killed by noise, and some of us are being killed faster than others. More after this. Support for this special two-part series exploring the power of sound to influence our health comes from the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation. The Robert Wood Johnson Foundation is working to build a culture of health that ensures everyone in America has a fair and just opportunity for health and well-being, which includes exploring how our current or future environments will impact daily life.
噪音还会损害我们的学业表现，搞砸我们的情绪，损害我们的注意力，基本上我们正在被噪音谋杀，而且我们中的一些人被谋杀的速度比其他人更快。广告之后更精彩。支持这个探索声音影响我们健康的强大力量的特殊的两部分系列的赞助来自罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会致力于建立一种健康文化，确保美国的每个人都有公平公正的机会获得健康和福祉，其中包括探索我们当前或未来的环境将如何影响日常生活。
Learn more at rwjf.org. We know noise causes health problems, but they can be especially pronounced if you live in a less affluent neighborhood. If we live in a place, for example, with lots of environmental noise, as do many people in American cities, especially people of color and low-income families, then we have to deal with essentially this mechanical sound that can shave off sort of the high frequencies just through repeated relentlessness. Neighborhoods near factories, highways, and flight paths are the loudest, and usually they're at the least expensive places to live.
在 rwjf.org 上了解更多信息。我们知道噪音会导致健康问题，但如果你住在不太富裕的社区，这些问题可能会尤为明显。如果我们居住的地方，例如，有很多环境噪声，正如美国城市中的许多人一样，尤其是少数族裔和低收入家庭，那么我们基本上不得不面对这种机械声音，它可以通过重复的无情轰鸣削弱高音部分。靠近工厂、高速公路和航线的街区噪音最大，通常也是居住成本最低的地方。
This is a noise equity problem. We should have the choice of living in a space that is not doing damage to us. Without having to move, we should have the agency to good health, good hearing health, and we should have agency over the things that could harm us essentially. The most obvious solution is to make laws.
这是一个噪声公平问题。我们应该有选择居住在不对我们造成损害的空间的权利。无需搬迁，我们应该拥有获得健康、良好听力健康的自主权，并且我们应该对基本上可能对我们造成伤害的事物拥有自主权。最明显的解决方案是立法。
Some cities carve out quiet hours. You can't run a noisy leaf blower or practice drumming in your garage at night or else you'll get fine. But there's a couple of problems with noise abatement loss. For one thing, they're often used to target vulnerable people. Noise abatement loss sort of always singled out, powerless people, people whose livelihoods impeded the sort of middle-class vision of a quiet or orderly or bustling city, etc.
一些城市设定了安静时间。你不能在夜间在车库里运行吵闹的吹叶机或练习打鼓，否则你会被罚款。但噪声防治法存在一些问题。一方面，它们经常被用来针对弱势群体。噪声防治法总是挑出无权无势的人，那些生计阻碍了中产阶级对安静、有序或繁华城市等的愿景的人。
Sort of like what this sort of bourgeois idea of what the ideal soundscape would be for the city. The very first restrictions on city noise came in the early 20th century in New York. A rich woman named Julia Barnett Rice campaigned to silence the horns and whistles from tugboats in the nearby port. All these noises were bothering her and her Riverside mansion. It's not hard to see the threat of connection from someone like Julia Barnett Rice and someone like Barbecue Becky, the white woman who called the police on a black family having a barbecue last year in Oakland. It was the beginning of what we call gentrification, which is pushing out those who rely on the city
有点像这种资产阶级对城市理想声景的想法。对城市噪音的最早限制出现在20世纪初的纽约。一个名叫朱莉娅·巴内特·莱斯的富有女人发起了一场运动，要求消除附近港口拖船的喇叭和汽笛声。所有这些噪音都在打扰她和她在河滨的大宅。不难看出朱莉娅·巴内特·莱斯这样的人与“烧烤贝基”（Barbecue Becky）之间的威胁联系，那个去年在奥克兰报警举报一个黑人家庭烧烤的白人女性。这是一些我们称之为士绅化（美化）的现象的开始，它将那些依靠城市生活的人挤出去
for work in order to satisfy the sort of aesthetic tastes of the wealthier people whose opinions were more of a concern to those in power. This is very much both a literal and a sonic displacement. The other problem with noise laws is that they aren't very effective. So the way we currently regulate and measure sound in our communities is by using this decibel. That's Erica Walker. Remember the decibel measures how loud something is, but most sound meters only listen to a specific range of frequencies, the kind that we hear with our ears. That's called an A-weighted system.
为了工作，为了满足更富裕人群的审美趣味，而这些人的意见更受当权者的关注。这在很大程度上既是字面上的也是声学上的流离失所。噪声法的另一个问题是它们不是很有效。因此，我们目前在社区中规范和测量声音的方法是使用这种分贝。那是埃里卡·沃克。记住分贝测量声音有多大，但大多数声级计只聆听特定频率范围的声音，即我们用耳朵听到的那种。这被称为A加权系统。
This A-weighted system that tells us that it's only the sounds that we process through the auditory system that are important. But there are some sounds we don't process with our ears. Once the pitch gets low enough, we no longer hear it, but feel it instead. It's completely vibrational, so it's just essentially that feeling. So when you're in a community that's in a flight path and you say it's 65 a-weighted decibels You're subtracting out the components that come from the lower frequency sound So you're leaving out a huge part of the story
这个A加权系统告诉我们，只有我们通过听觉系统处理的声音才是重要的。但有些声音我们不是用耳朵处理的。一旦音调低到一定程度，我们就再也听不到它，而是去感受它。它是完全振动的，所以它基本上只是那种感觉。因此，当你处于一条航线下的社区并说它是65个A加权分贝时，你减去了来自低频声音的成分，所以你遗漏了故事的很大一部分。
Not only is it a flawed metric they're using this metric to determine who's eligible for sound proofing criteria material. Erika is working on a project called the Community Noise Lab, and she hopes that by taking a much wider range of frequencies into account, we can get a better grasp of how sounds are affecting our neighborhoods and our health. In the meantime, Kate Wagner says that there are steps everyone can take to make things sound a little better. You can make acoustics changes to the spaces you're in. There are sort of architectural and design choices that we can make to make our spaces a little
这不仅是一个有缺陷的指标，他们还在使用这个指标来确定谁有资格获得隔音标准材料。埃里卡正在参与一个名为社区噪音实验室的项目，她希望通过将更广泛的频率范围考虑在内，我们能够更好地掌握声音如何影响我们的社区和健康。与此同时，凯特·瓦格纳表示，每个人都可以采取一些步骤让声音听起来更好一点。你可以对你所在的fromRGB空间进行声学更改。我们可以做出一些建筑和设计选择，让我们的空间更小
bit quieter. You can always choose to sort of beef up the insulation or have a floating floor, any other sort of expensive solutions that are more structural to isolating noise. You can also hang thicker curtains, which is cool because velvet is in. Velvet curtains might be a solution to noise problems in our home, but addressing the noise from cars and industry requires a fundamental change to the way we live.
有点安静。你总能选择加强隔音或安装浮动地板，以及任何其他对隔离噪音更具结构性的昂贵解决方案。你也可以挂更厚的窗帘，这很酷，因为天鹅绒现在正流行。天鹅绒窗帘可能是我们家中噪音问题的解决方案，但要解决汽车和工业带来的噪音，需要对我们的生活方式进行根本性的改变。
Often, the things that are making the most noise, especially sort of industrial noise, are the things that are perhaps not exactly the healthiest. For the environment, for example, it takes a lot more noise to have a natural gas plant or drill or do what have you for any kind of sort of extractive purposes than it does to have a solar farm, which is almost entirely silent.
通常，制造最大噪音的东西，尤其是某种工业噪音，往往不是最健康的。例如，对环境而言，建设天然气发电厂、钻探或进行任何开采目的的活动所产生的噪音，要比几乎完全无声的太阳能农场大得多。
The quietest city I've ever been in that was a major city was Helsinki in Finland. I was astonished because the metro or the subway trains and the buses and not their silent. The train stations are very quiet. That's partly because the majority of their trains are electric, but it's also down to the design of their stations. From a mixture of materials, sound absorbing materials, and also psychochistic tricks like
我去过的大城市中，最安静的城市是芬兰的赫尔辛基。我很惊讶，因为地铁或地铁列车和公共汽车并不是无声的。火车站非常安静。这部分是因为他们的大多数列车都是电动的，但这也归因于他们车站的设计。由多种材料、吸音材料以及心理声学技巧混合而成，比如
pumping in noise that has this weird reverse effect of making things seem quieter, which is a technique used in offices as well. The fins are able to make spaces quieter, and the idea that they should be quieter seems to be more popular there. Perhaps the quieter public spaces play a small part in making Finland reportedly the happiest country in the world. It's a country that is so taken into account the public good from all aspects, things like healthcare, childcare, social services, a robust welfare state, and things like their outlook on sustainability.
注入具有这种奇怪的反向效果的噪音，使事情看起来更安静，这也是办公室使用的一种技术。芬兰人能够让空间更安静，而且它们应该更安静的想法在那里似乎更受欢迎。也许更安静的公共空间在使芬兰据称成为世界上最幸福的国家方面发挥了小小的作用。这是一个在方方面面都如此考虑到公共利益的国家，诸如医疗保健、儿童保育、社会服务、强大的福利国家等事物，以及他们对可持续发展的看法。
So cleaner, quieter vehicles make you happier. And when things are less noisy, there's a great opportunity to create a richer and more useful sonic landscape. Electric cars don't naturally make a sound. So if you've ever had one creep up on you, it's a really, really scary experience. Joel Buckerman says this silence of electric cars can actually be a drawback. Total silence is not
因此，更清洁、更安静的车辆会让你更快乐。当噪音较小时，这是一个创造更丰富、更有用的声景的绝佳机会。电动汽车不会自然发出声音。所以如果你曾经历过它悄悄靠近你，那真的是一次非常非常可怕的经历。乔尔·布克曼表示，电动汽车的这种安静实际上可能是一个缺点。绝对安静并不是
a good thing. In fact, Joel says that electric cars need to make noise, or else they won't be safe. It's not for the people in the car. It's for the pedestrians to know that the car is coming. the car, it's for the pedestrians to know that the car is coming. But the opportunity is also to create a personality for the vehicle, for the electric vehicles. He actually worked with Nissan to create an identity for their new electric car. Here it is, coming right at you. In this case, what we were looking to do was create a car that had a personality, which is really an association with clean energy. One of the things we knew is it's going to be frictionless.
一件好事。事实上，乔尔说电动汽车需要制造噪音，否则它们就不安全。这不是为了车里的人。这是为了让行人知道汽车正在驶来。汽车，这是为了让行人知道汽车正在驶来。但这也是一个为汽车创造个性的机会，为电动汽车创造个性。他实际上与日产合作，为他们的新款电动车创造了一个标识。给你，它正朝你开来。在这种情况下，我们希望做的是创造一辆具有个性的汽车，这实际上与清洁能源有关。我们知道的一件事是它将是无摩擦的。
When you hear a car accelerate, if it accelerates very quickly, let's say, and there is a sense of really smoothness, lack of friction, there is almost a natural ambience to it. We actually used natural sounds, but it still sounds like a car and it absolutely had to, because we don't have pedestrians to hear it and say, oh, what's that, and get hit by the car. Joel wants a future city dominated by natural sounds, but also sounds that we've consciously chosen.
当你听到一辆汽车加速时，假设它加速非常快，并且有一种真正的平稳感、缺乏摩擦感，它几乎有一种自然的氛围。我们实际上使用了自然声音，但它听起来仍然像一辆汽车，而且它绝对必须如此，因为我们没有行人听到它并说，哦，那是什么，然后被车撞。乔尔希望未来的城市由自然声音主导，同时也由我们自觉选择的声音主导。
Some cities are already taking a more thoughtful approach. In the Tokyo subway station, each station has a little tune associated with it. And if you know anything about the Japanese subway system, it is packed. So if you're in the middle of a car, and you miss an announcement because it's noisy, you're sunk. You're gonna miss your stop.
一些城市已经在采取更深思熟虑的方法。在东京地铁站，每个车站都有一首与之相关的小曲。如果你对日本地铁系统有所了解，它非常拥挤。所以如果你在车厢中间，因为吵闹而错过了广播，你就完了。你会错过你的站。
The Tokyo trains have a short jingle unique to each and every station along the line, like this one for Ekebu Kuro Station on the Yamano Te Line. These little tunes that show up at each station helps you understand where you are, and also they're pleasing. They're not a screaming announcement. We could live in cities full of intentional sounds, with soundscapes that we've chosen. You might find some of these new sounds really pleasant, or really annoying. But the nice thing is, you'll get to decide that for yourself, because you'll be able to hear them all. This special episode of 99% Invisible was produced by Laila Batasin and Dallas Taylor, with
东京的列车为线上的每一个车站都提供了一个独特的简短叮咚声，就像山手线上池袋站的这个一样。这些出现在各个车站的小曲子可以帮你了解你身在何处，而且它们很悦耳。它们不是尖叫的公告。我们可以生活在充满意图的声音的城市中，伴随着我们选择的声景。你可能会发现其中一些新声音非常悦耳，或者非常烦人。但好的一点是，你将自己决定这一点，因为你将能够听到它们全部。这个特殊的 99% Invisible 节目由莱拉·巴塔辛（Laila Batasin）和达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）制作，并得到了
help from Sam Sneepley, edited by Chris Baroubaix, sound design and mix by Colin Devarnie, music by Sean Real. Special thanks to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation and man-made music who contributed as executive producers and providing the soundscapes in the show. the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation and Manmade Music, who contributed as executive producers in providing the soundscapes in the show. Joel Buckerman, his written book, it's called The Sonic Boom, How Sound transforms the way we think, feel, and buy, go check it out. You can learn more about these stories and other topics related to Sonic Humanism and sounds effects on our health by visiting info.sonichumanism.com.
萨姆·斯内普利（Sam Sneepley）的帮助，克里斯·巴鲁拜克斯（Chris Baroubaix）剪辑，科林·德瓦尼（Colin Devarnie）声音设计和混音，肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）音乐。特别感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会和人造音乐公司（Manmade Music），他们作为执行制片人做出了贡献，并为节目提供了声景。罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会和人造音乐公司（Manmade Music），他们作为执行制片人贡献了节目中的声景。乔尔·布克曼写了一本书，叫做《声爆：声音如何改变我们的思考、感受和购买方式》（The Sonic Boom, How Sound transforms the way we think, feel, and buy），去看看吧。你可以访问 info.sonichumanism.com 了解更多关于这些故事以及与声音人文主义和声音对我们健康的影响相关的主题。
Thanks also to our guest, Kate Wagner, Erica Walker, and Matthias Bassner. You can find out more about Erica's Community Noise Lab at communitynoyslab.org. Thanks again to the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation for their underwriting support of this special series. Learn more about their efforts to help create a culture of health at rwjf.org. Foundation for their underwriting support of this special series. Learn more about their efforts to help create a culture of health at rwjf.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还要感谢我们的嘉宾凯特·瓦格纳、埃里卡·沃克和马蒂亚斯·巴斯纳。你可以在 communitynoyslab.org 上了解更多关于埃里卡的社区噪音实验室的信息。再次感谢罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会对这个特别系列的大力支持。在 rwjf.org 上了解更多关于他们帮助创建健康文化的努力。基金会对这个特别系列的大力支持。在 rwjf.org 上了解更多关于他们帮助建立健康文化的努力。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。